une présence symbolique pour un verdict
très attendu quinze ans après
l'assassinât de rafic hariri
la justice désigne un coupable par le
tribunal spécial pour le liban condamne
salim ayyash le coordonnateur d'un acte
terroriste aux visées politiques
ces trois présumés complices aussi
membres du hezbollah sont acquittés
faute de preuves
en 2005 l'explosion d'une camionnette
piégée a tué un politicien populaire
accentuer les divisions religieuses et
plongé le liban dans une autre période
chaotique avant sa mort violente
rafic hariri souhaitait réduire
l'influencé de la syrie dans son pays si
ce n'est d'en quête et des centaines de
millions de dollars n'ont pas permis
d'identifier les commanditaires de
l'attentât
la syrie le hezbollah avait peut-être
des raisons d'éliminer rafic hariri mais
aucune preuve ne confirment leur
implication directe
les attentes étaient bien plus élevés
mais le fils du politicien assassiné qui
accepte tout de même le verdict à
beyrouth le cratère causé par
l'explosion de 2005 a été comblé la
mémoire de rafic hariri reste bien
vivante
mais les esprits sont ailleurs
il n'y a rien de plus important que les
suites de l'explosion survenue il ya
deux semaines dans cette hausse il faut
identifier les coupables ajoute un autre
autre quête de justice et de vérité pour
le liban un pays qui ne cesse de compter
ses morts et ses déceptions
ici elle est dûment baron radio-canada
paris